one of the critical things for us was to
look also at our employees potential new
employees as well as existing ones
so for example one of the criterias was
let's look at our employer brand and
when you build in the strategy for
branding it's not only for external
markets
but it also for your own employee and
how you connect the new branding
to your employees and potential
candidates to recruit
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to be joined by amit
daniel
chief marketing officer and strategy of
cognite amita nail is a marketing leader
with two decades of experience in global
high tech companies
since joining the cognite business in
2015 amit has been responsible for
global marketing employer brand and
demand generation for driving business
growth
prior to joining the cognite business
amit was evp marketing and products at
cvd now an amdux company and vice
president of marketing business
development and products at starhome
now tomia amid daniel welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm very good how are you i'm doing
great we're gonna have
such a fun time talking about your role
as chief marketing officer
of cognite but you know before that the
senior vice president of marketing of
variant cyber intelligence not two
different
distinct companies we're going to be
talking about that as well but
your whole journey in the in in
marketing roles is both
also as executive vice president of
previous companies uh i think that
there's
a lot that we're going to be talking
about in the world of rebranding and
thinking
through you know what's 2021 like and
going through such processes so before
we get to
to what you've done with variance take
me back a little bit into your career
and and your journey in marketing roles
well i started you know um i did my mba
abroad i studied in the uk
and after i did my first degree in
business and international marketing
both in israel and in the uk and when i
came back
as a matter of fact i didn't start for
marketing even though that was my major
study
um i started from product management and
i spent almost 10 years in that area
doing product management in startups and
managing
product management teams across high
tech and technology companies
and then after everything basically you
know like connected
we collected the dots i finally
understood that you know a very
fascinating job like product
management is tightly coupled when it
comes to marketing because you can bring
in the understanding of the customer and
the market
and the passion that you bring in
developing new products
also when it comes to marketing and then
after i shifted and i started managing
both
product management marketing as well as
business development
and i did it in few teams um and
activities across
several tech companies for me marketing
is storytelling i mean
that's that's the beauty being creatine
being surrounded with
very creative people and being able to
create a brand and a story
that is used by different channels and
different audiences and
if you're doing it right it's impacting
everything that you do your customers
your partners
investors employees it's all tied up
together
so i love marketing very very cool now
tell me
you know this concept of rebranding you
know this journey that is called
rebranding you know it's a it i think
that it it require it's a little bit
heavier than what
you know just the name suggests the
simplicity of it it's not that simple
tell me a little bit what rebranding is
you know as a strategical point of view
and then we'll talk a little bit about
your experience with it
sure what rebranding is really a
strategic process it's not the tactical
one and sometimes you know people are
thinking okay i'll just you know create
a visual identity
and logo and take it you know practical
just to make sure that it's done into
the marketing operation
it's completely not the concept i think
that if you really understand that
branding is all about that's your window
i mean that's your window to any kind of
audiences
and then you need to make sure that you
think what you want to convey
what's your messaging how you want to
what will be the perception of the
markets employees investors about you
you need to start really asking very
difficult and complex questions when you
start a rebranding process
and as a matter of fact i think that one
of the main insights if you want to add
a successful rebranding process
is to make sure that you clearly
understand the messaging the narrative
before you jump into the actual
implementation and execution
of branding and logos and visuals and
websites etc
so that's really by itself and in order
to do that strategically you need to
cover
different aspects you need to clearly
understand what's your strategy of the
company
you need to understand what your
competitors are doing and what's
going to differentiate you when you
stand out and you convey your message
and it comes across even if you keep
your name and you just change your
identity visually and messaging wise
but clearly when you're changing our
name which was the case when we shifted
from varying to cognite
it was even more complicated because you
need to pick a name that really
represents what you do
and conveys properly the story outside
and they take it into the visual and the
different types of implementation
so if i need to summarize it it's a
strategic process
now why so what would be the company
especially a company that's
operating for many many years to go
through a rebranding process which
obviously is
is a complicated process yeah it's
really complicated because
we need to re rebrand and we need to
rename
so the initial process was to set our
goals
what would you like to achieve in this
process i mean what will be the end game
how we would like to be perceived by the
different audiences and this is where we
started from myself and
my amazing marketing team together with
the external agency
and once we met this one we really
looked at everything so i can tell you
for example we started in our case
we called it name storm just like
brainstorm
because we needed to come initially with
a replacement to vary because we spun
off
out from varying to be our independent
standalone company
traded in asda um and after 25 years
having a massive reputation being a
market leader
everybody in the space of security
analytics software
new is very it was quite challenging
because you need to come up with a new
name
a new identity for a market that knows
you very well
and when we started doing that the
initial ones was
really to define the criteria so you
need to think of a name that represents
what you want to do and what's your
vision and roadmap as a company
and from our side for example uh
we had some criterias we wanted it to be
representing the name what we do we
wanted it to be
really simple you know to pronounce we
wanted to make sure because we're a
global company
that it fits uh different languages and
it's not going to contradict in
other languages you know um in anything
that it will be problematic and we set
up the entire criterions and i can tell
you it was
fascinating so we're already talking
specifically about
about you know the specific process that
you you've been going through over the
last few months tell me a little bit
more
specifically about you know the
strategic thinking that goes on from
transitioning from there and to cognite
okay so the process then was really to
say okay
who we are what's our message what's our
differentiating how do we stand out
versus our competitors so as part of the
process
what we have done is we really looked at
what cognite is doing and what we're
doing
is we are providing different types of
technologies to our customers
in order to have a stateful world so
what we do is we accelerate their
investigations
and we want to make sure that we can
predict and prevent the threat
before it's actually taking place and
for that you need massive analytics that
assist and our customers are being
empowered with our technology
so starting from that we say okay we're
a security analytics
company that's clearly need to come out
in everything in the rebranding in the
visual identity and the tone of voice
in the messaging in the creative that
was one of the criteria
the other thing was because we left we
spun up from
bearing we wanted it to be very
different from variance so we defined it
for example there will be no v
there will be no no uh something that
will stand out will be very different
from very because we really wanted to
create a differentiation
i must say that one of the things that
for us was critical and i strongly
believe it is a cmo
when you speak about branding many of
the cmos usually
think about immediately their customers
investors
partners one of the critical things for
us
was to look also at our employees
potential new employees as well as
existing ones
so for example one of the criterias was
let's look at our employer brand and
when you build in the strategy for
branding it's not only for external
markets
but it also for your own employee and
how you connect the new branding
to your employees and potential
candidates to recruit
and we have our employer brand we had it
also invariant it's called curious
because we're very curious people this
is our dna and what represents us as a
company
and for us building the new name and
connecting it to everything that
involves branding
part of the strategy was also to connect
the employer brand
nowadays when you look at the
competition out there and you know for
talents and recruitment
and retaining employees it's a critical
element when it comes to strategy and
branding
because sometimes it's being neglected
and once you get to it it's too late you
need to make sure that when you plan an
end in branding
look at it as part of your strategy so
what so what was actually the
tangible action steps that were taken
internally within the company
to align everybody to this new to this
new language
this is this new culture that you're
creating fantastic question
i must tell you that was the top top top
lesson learned
for any branding process if you wanted
to be successful
you need to make sure that you start
from in
to out and you need to make sure that
all your employees
across the board from every department
are engaged and i can tell you that
doing that during coffee
where initially when i started the
process there was no coffee
egg covered around and we just imagined
how we're going to do the communication
and the launches everything
physically we have 17 offices seven r d
centers all over the world you know big
shows
and suddenly it all started you know
immediately when we started working on
the process everything became virtually
and i must tell you that even though it
was
a huge challenge i think that was
one of the main criterias for it being
so successful because we had to think
out of the box
we had to then come and say okay we want
to engage our employees globally
and one of the things that is really
critical is that sometimes marketing
departments for them branding you know
it's a
dream come true once in a lifetime but
it's sometimes perceived as a marketing
act and responsibility and if you forget
and you only come back to your
organizations and employees
at the end just be the result you're
missing a huge opportunity the
opportunity of engagement
opportunity of communication so what we
did
from the very first beginning we planned
as part of our execution and strategy
how we're going to engage
and make sure that our employees are
part of the process
step by step by the way much before we
communicated it externally
to our customers partners and investors
so they
were part of our secret and just to
prove that it works
it's that they kept it as a secret and
we're a company above 2000 employees
which is quite complicated
okay just think about it i mean
we exposed to them the names months
before it was out there on social
we had 139 different names
that we had to pick one from and we
exposed it
to all of them we explained to them what
was the process what was the
brainstorming behind it
how we looked at our competitors all the
logic of a branding process
now just think about a technology person
that usually does a very type of
activity during his day and he doesn't
understand
anything about breaking and you come up
and you share with them you explain how
it is done what's the process what's the
logic
why you pick this versus why you didn't
pick others
and people were so enthusiastic about it
because they felt connected they felt
that they were
sharing the same secret with us and they
didn't reveal it
it was amazing for months and then after
when we had the visual identity we again
did a virtual event
put everybody on board we did it
interactive with them
and exposed what our visual identity
what's our messaging what's our tone of
voice
then after they were engaged and we saw
the results you know
when you look at social before we
started the nasdaq activity in february
and we all started to show you and
expose the brand
you could see it in the results of the
social networks on linkedin on facebook
on twitter on youtube
there were so engaged and proud they
felt like it was their own baby
and i think it's really really critical
to remember that
and not expose them at the end you know
when the rest of the world knows about
the branding
but do it from the first stage that they
were
you know doing the naming or branding is
like setting up a name for a new baby
okay people always everything to say
they always
people will not you know someone like it
some will say
ah it's terrible some will say that your
logo
or visual they don't like it it was a
consensus
so they were so attached to it and they
looked at it in the different processes
it's really one of the top successful
criteria for making a successful
branding process
unbelievable but then you have over a
thousand customers right for cognitive
in many many countries
what is the next step how do you then
take this now shared secret
bring it out to the world but then
expose it to over a thousand paying
customers
that have aligned with one brand they
are trusting and they're paying for that
brand
and now there's a whole new brand which
is also much more startup-like
so and on top of that it's all done
eventually so you don't have trade shows
and face-to-face interactions to show
them
right you have to do everything remotely
okay
so that was one of the major challenges
but again you know
we translated the lemon to be a lemonade
and what we did just like we did
internally with our own employees
we didn't stay with our customers and
partners
so what we did we did a virtual event
equivalent to what we have done and we
showed them behind the scenes of the
branding
now think to a customer again is
completely out of scope has nothing to
do with marketing and branding
and you as a supplier he's now sharing
with him
why you pick the name what's the logic
behind it ignite by itself
as a meaning it's a combination of
cognition and ignite
so we have to explain why we picked the
name why we picked it versus other
alternatives
what it represents what's in it for them
why it's so important
and what's what it's going to bring to
them is a new identity moving forward
connecting us to the strategy what's the
impact
on the relationship we all communicated
it was communicated globally
then after with our sales team directly
with our customers
and then after we took it into social
activities
across the different channels then after
two workshops
then after we took it to trade shows and
we're starting to see it physically
taking place
we send gifts so i can tell you just as
an example
when before the we ranked the bell in
nasdaq in february
and think about the employees we
fixed all the branding globally 17
offices
nobody was in the office just imagine
that so
you left the company like a year and you
don't know what's happening there's a
surprise but actually all the signage
all the interior design everything
was modified completely no sign left to
variant at february
1st of february it was all good night
across the world
everywhere but the employees couldn't
feel it in the corridors
so and we wanted to connect them to that
feeling because we didn't know when
they'll be back in the office
what we did we took videos of all the
offices
in the change in the transition from
variant to cognite
and then after we did clips that show
how we spread the color and the new
brand of cognite across the different
offices
we sent to their families better tone
gift with swag with cognite so they
could share it with their friends like
you know sweatshirts and chocolates and
bells to ring the
nasdam and lots of stuff and it got
their
foot door at home which is by itself
incredible i mean 2 000
employees globally receiving a package
and a delivery
and now they can share it with their
friends and family which by itself
makes it really exciting and what we
also did
is they all took pictures and video you
can see it all over in our
digital channels and when we add to ring
the bell
again the ringing of the belt didn't
happen in usda because it was closed
during to
cover so what we did is we asked all our
employees to take pictures of them with
their
parents and families and they all
appeared
on the tower of nazda without actually
being there
but they could see themselves and
everything that was done remotely
even though it was remotely they were
tightly coupled you know
as if they were in a time square at the
same time
wow so it was all working together
across the different uh
employees and channels and it was
amazing i mean
at the beginning you know we were crazy
how we're going to make it uh
virtually and at the end it only made us
being much more global
and accessible to different audiences
incredible they're just incredible and
uh and i
i can only imagine how not stressful but
how
rigorous it must have been going through
such a transition
so meticulous and so detailed and so
strategic
having to really you know even just
understand how everybody's reacting in
life
in in real time and and and being aware
that you have over 2 000 employees
over a thousand paying customers and so
many countries i can only imagine how
uh how many sleepless nights you must
have had on there and i think it's just
incredible
how smooth the transition was and how
celebratory and
it ended up being so a really really an
amazing story and thank you for taking
the time to share it with me i have
a few more questions not about cook
night or the rebranding but about you
amit
and i want you to take me back to your
childhood now and
tell me what really fascinated you as a
kid
well there's so many things but i can
tell you that one of the
top ones is getting to know people from
different cultures
i traveled when i was young to places
you know when you live in your
neighborhood then usually you know
people that are very similar to you
coming from similar background
so you all look the same you study in
the same school you go to the same
activities
and for me it was cultures it was to
really find and learn about things that
are very different from where he was
born and grew
and i did it a lot by reading initially
there was no internet and social
networks unfortunately when i was a
child
but every time that i traveled and i did
lots of
youth exchange and traveling abroad and
you know
seeing people it always made me so
curious and so interested about stuff
that i don't see on my daily activity
and it was about the cultures the people
i'm a people's person so
every time that i could see something
very different from me i really felt
that
that fascinates me i mean i'm learning
how much what i'm not
and what i can be and i'm looking at
different types of people and
personalities
that was always there fascinating for me
as a kid
amazing and and you know today in your
day-to-day what really inspires you
well i have people
that break barriers i mean people to do
things that
you know you're suddenly looking at that
and they said
wow i couldn't do that i mean so for me
anything that
is uh if i look and say wow they did
stuff that nobody expected that they
will be successful
or they you know they broke the ceiling
and it's whether people you know living
in places
that they didn't enable them to get the
infrastructure and they suddenly managed
to do something
so extreme and can reach eyes that
you know it's very difficult to to reach
or to break
for me it's you know i always take off
my
act and i'm saying wow it's incredible
and i come across
in different industries in different
places i'm also volunteering with people
uh that are coming from different
backgrounds and you know to see them
achieving stuff that is not always
standard
and always succeeding or doing stuff for
other people you know
as being a role models for them
that's for me is amazing the people that
can balance between you know their
personal life and
work and find the time you know to
assist other people to break the
the feeling or to do things that are
inspiring
i mean i wish i had more time to do that
but i always appreciate and you know
look at people that do manage to juggle
between them
for me it's always an inspiration
amazing and what are three words you
used to describe yourself
whoa well you know i must say my
employer brand is curious
and i'm so much associated with this one
i'm a curious person i'm curious about
technology i'm curious about
people i'm a people's person if you ask
me that's the second one
for me sitting in front of a computer
working by myself
is impossible i'll be dead if i'll do
that so i really need to be surrounded
by people and different people and work
as part of the team
and energy i mean i mean high speed i
like to
work all the time you know to motivate
myself
to look for new eyes to cross i need
high speed energy
that's my that's what makes me you know
think and walk up every morning
i i can feel it resonating through
through the screen amit thank you so so
much thank you for sharing this
fascinating journey
this was great uh and thank you for
sharing everything with me stay safe and
stay
thank you for the time thank you bye-bye
take care
bye